[Music]
welcome everyone to our inaugural
Android developer summit here at the
Computer History Museum in Mountain View
California it's great to see so many
Android developers here from some of the
biggest names an emerging names all
under one roof
and I also want to say a big welcome to
everybody who's joining us on the
livestream today
ok so speaking of history I joined
Google in 2007 and it was a time when
computing was quite different so the
focus really of the company was really
laptops and desktops and it was before
Mobile had really taken off and Larry
and Sergey the the cofounders of Google
to their credit kind of foresaw how
mobile was gonna change how we interact
with computers on a daily basis and so
they wanted to create a strategic
investment in mobile so we grew it
created a separate group within Google
to focus on mobile applications and the
goal of the group was to take existing
Google Apps and services and bring them
to the mobile phones at the time now
remember this was 2007 so it was a
pretty different world and in particular
there was no Android and there was no
iPhone and the devices that were
available at the time were quite
primitive so you had a whole
fragmentation of technologies across
different device manufacturers so you
would see j2me and one device maker you
would see Symbian and then even within
Symbian there were two variants uiq and
s60 you'd have Palm OS you'd have
Windows Mobile and it was brutal as an
application developer tap to target all
of these different SDKs because each one
would have different capabilities and
limitations and what you would
invariably find is that because they're
so different you would have to hire
application developers for each
technology vertical it was really really
tough but we sold it on and we created a
whole set of applications and services
so we had wack versions of Google search
we had HTML versions of Google's
Church we still have like radio buttons
yet did I tell Google whether you were
searching for web or images I was before
we had something called Universal Search
we had j2me versions of maps we had j2me
versions of YouTube of gmail etcetera
even within Google Maps not only do we
have j2me versions we had a windows
mobile version we had a series 60
version you've got a uiq version we had
a Palm OS version with an HTML version
it was very very tough and it was very
very tough to scale even even for a
company with the resources like Google
so we needed something better which then
brought us to Android and at the time
you know when analysts would hear about
the Android project they would sort of
criticize it and they would be like ok
this is the last thing the world needs
is yet another mobile operating system
and Andy Rubin who started the Android
project he would agree but he would say
what the world needs is an open-source
mobile operating system and so what
Android we also want a platform that has
the application developer in mind so we
spend a lot of time worrying and
thinking about our API design to make
sure that we have a really good
application framework every year when we
do a desert release we have we run what
we call API console and it's a group of
core engineers on the team and they
review all the prospective new api's all
the method names all that the property
names all of the all of the sort of
styles that people are using across the
team and we make sure that we have one
consistent style so if you're writing an
application and you're interacting we'll
say with our camera to API s and then
you're talking to sensor manager to read
sensor readings or you're manipulating
your view hierarchy we wanted to feel
like it's one person had designed those
API is for you even more important is
making sure that we have consistency of
those API is across different devices
and so the way we do that is we have
something we call a compatibility
definition document and it's a document
describing all of the requirements that
a compatible device must exhibit and
it's backed by hundreds of thousands of
tests that we call the compatibility
test suite and so if you're a device
maker and you want to make an Android
device you have to pass these hundreds
of five
of tests to be able to use the Android
brand and for your device to be able to
access the Play Store and what this does
is it ensures that you as an application
developer can target applications that
work across a variety of device makers
and then you as a user can download apps
and have certainty that the app will run
well on your device so CTS is an ongoing
project we're consistent constantly
investing in it in just the last 12
months we've added over eighty thousand
OpenGL tests for example and this allows
us to test some of the very latest
features in OpenGL right up to 3.1 and
it ensures that if you're a game
developer and you're using those latest
features in OpenGL we can make sure that
they're gonna work well on modern
devices so of course now what this
enables other people not only third
parties but even Google's first parties
we can now use Google Android's public
API to deliver very advanced services
things like navigation and Google Maps
or or VR with cardboard these are
features that would have been extremely
difficult if not impossible on previous
platforms so so what's happening that
well effectively we're in the midst of a
mobile revolution we just announced last
month over 50% of Google searches are
now happening on mobile and for me
having started in 2007 this is an
incredible number to see I remember we
would look at traffic graphs and we
would literally see mobile was like this
little blip where's now it's takes a
path of the of the area and of course
Android is on a tear we have over 1.4
billion 30-day active users across all
form factors and as you know a lot of
that is also thanks to you guys because
you know a platform of that applications
is not a product and so thank you for
all of the work that you guys do you
know it's kind of interesting you know
we think about it because over the next
couple of years especially emerging
markets people who don't have phones are
gonna be getting phones and all phones
are gonna become smartphones it's just
an amazing transition to be a part of
and you know some people actually
predicted this I love this quote this is
from Nikola Tesla in 1926 and he talks
about you know
being able to communicate with each
other instantly right irrespective of
distance he talks about being able to
see each other perfectly as though we
were face to face and he talks about
devices being amazingly simple he
finishes up and he says a man will be
able to carry one in his vest pocket I
mean this is very prescient I mean he
obviously didn't anticipate that women
would like phones but he can't be
perfect this was 90 years ago hopefully
we've moved on but it's pretty amazing
to see now of course
mobile technology is advancing super
fast and on the Android team we like to
have a very fast pace and so if I just
looked take a little walk down memory
lane
so in 2009 we launched we actually have
three desert releases in one year so we
did cupcake we did donut we did Eclair
and even when those three releases we
released some pretty profound at the
time features so we had third-party
replaceable keyboards for example we had
voice search available we had desktop
class browsing then a 2010 we did two
more releases we did Froyo and we did
gingerbread and we introduced additional
features like NFC and Wi-Fi hotspot' and
the native development kit for targeting
games then in the next year we did
honeycomb and Ice Cream Sandwich
so honeycomb allowed us to bring Android
2 tablets Ice Cream Sandwich then
introduced a more refined UI with the
holo theme and also introducing the
Roboto font for the first time which
you'll not see everywhere on Android
fast-forward there with jellybean and we
had KitKat which then brings us to our
two most recent releases lollipop and
marshmallow so with lollipop this was an
opportunity for us to expand the
categories of computing that Android
could run on so we introduced support
for wearables for watches for TV and for
Android auto and cars and then this year
we introduced marshmallow and the focus
there was to go back to the core user
experience and set a high bar for the
what we believe a quality experience and
polished experience on mobile should be
just last year we started a Developer
Preview process and further refined at
this
so what marshmallow we came out with a
set of preview releases across the
summer and even in the first couple of
days we had hundreds of thousands of
downloads and so what that means is that
hundreds of thousands of developers can
start testing out their applications on
the newest version of Android before the
release and you could also try the new
features so it's really awesome because
it means we're all working together to
have the best platform releases and the
best quality apps and services out
launched for our users ok so moving for
that was a little bit about timing and
we started to think about well what else
could we do to make your lives a little
bit easier and more productive what is
it that you spend all your time doing
now Android studio is the official
Android IDE and toolchain for for
Android directly from Google and it has
the best set of tools to help you build
better more successful apps this year
we've made a huge step wise change in
investment in our tools and we're
working on some really great features
that are rolling at both this year and
you'll see over the next coming months
and years I'm really excited about what
we're doing and to help you learn more
I'd like to invite Steph up to the stage
to talk to you about studio
thank you guys so much for being here
today
Android studio has built tremendous
momentum since we announced it about two
and a half years ago since we announced
we've had a hundred and three releases
into our various channels that includes
canary beta and stable Android studio
went g8 came out of beta just about a
year ago and since then we've had
another five major stable releases the
last two focused very heavily on quality
and stability in the Android studio team
our goal is to make the IDE delightful
and in order to be delightful we felt
like it had to be not just stable but
incredibly stable and that's because as
a developer you spend hours in the IDE
every day and so in 1.4 and 1.5 we felt
like with those significant investments
well we'll continue to make investments
in stability and quality and every
release we had the foundation that we
wanted to start setting our sights on
the next set of improvements which are
really gonna focus on speed now when we
took a look at the features that we had
planned for the next release we decided
it was so gigantic that we wanted to
renumber the release so you'll see the
next version of Android studio will be
Android studio 2.0
now this is a gigantic release I'm gonna
walk you through some of the feature set
today when we talk to mobile developers
there was a few things we found
particularly that there were a number of
opportunities to make the development
process faster smoother and better in
particular when we talked to mobile
developers like all developers we found
that you spend a ton of time we spend a
ton of time in the code build run cycle
writes where you spend all your time and
now if you think about what's like to
code on HTML you make some code edits
and then you can refresh the page live
right so it's super fast now how many of
you guys would say it feels that way on
mobile we felt like it was just too slow
it's too heavy weight and you had to be
able to iterate better so I'm gonna talk
about a bunch of changes the first thing
you'll see coming is we've massively
accelerated build speeds so in 2.0 full
build the first time you build will be
two to two and a half times faster than
it was so before your build was taking
you a minute now it's gonna be about 20
25 seconds
[Applause]
now I know a lot of you guys know too
after you do a full build then of course
you do an incremental build that's when
you do the second set of changes build a
second time incremental build speeds are
gonna be even faster than that they're
gonna be in the single-digit seconds and
I'm gonna come back to that and talk
about it more so the next thing I want
to talk about is the emulator in the
code build run cycle in order to iterate
you need to be able to quickly see how
the app looks as well
now a lot of you guys in the community
talk to us about our emulators and
here's what you said they are not fast
enough they are not stable enough we
listen to you guys and the truth was
you're right so we've made massive
improvements here in 2.0 we have made
major changes let me just start by
talking about speed because i fairly
feel like it's the most important in
Toronto one of the first things you'll
find is that they are significantly
faster we have a DB push speeds that are
five times faster for the emulator than
they are on a physical device we've
massively accelerated i/o we've
massively accelerated CPU so we're also
adding SMP support to take advantage of
hosts multi-core architecture you will
find overall that the emulators are
massively faster than they were before
we would also say the emulators continue
to include Google Play services so a ton
of the developers in the audience here
today and worldwide use Google Play
services to get access to things like
AdMob Maps authentication and those will
all be present just as you'd expect now
in addition to significant speed
improvements we also completely rewrote
the UI so you'll see major changes here
and in 2.0 you'll have screen rotation
screenshots windows zooming of the
emulator window you'll be able to take
an apk and drag and drop it on to the
emulator I will say a personal favorite
of our engineering director and one that
he pushed really far at pour a couple of
you guys in the audience asked us for
the ability to grab the edge of the
emulator and pull it down and back to
resize it and you will also find that
[Applause]
so that's not all you're gonna find
you'll have the ability to emulate GPS
location so you can pass in a single
point you can pass in a set of points
like you know me walking over to the
keynote today you can emulate calls you
can emulate texts you can emulate camera
you can mr8 emulate battery state so you
want to see how your apps gonna perform
when the battery's full or really drain
so overall a very very significant set
of changes in the emulator again the
reason why we felt this was so critical
is you have to be able to iterate in
your app and fast and every minute that
you're sitting around you're waiting for
builds you're waiting for run speed
that's a minute wasted so with 2.0 the
IDE is designed to help you stay
constantly in the flow while you're
coding so you can iterate and try things
out on a single device now one of the
things Dave talked about is we have 1.4
billion active users on Android and so
that means there's also a ton of devices
out there and that was another reason
why we felt the emulator was so
important so you could test not just on
the device that you have next to you but
across a multitude of devices one of the
things that we hear from developers
everywhere is that the emulator is very
important but physical devices are
important as well and that's why we have
decided to have world-class support for
both so let me talk about some more
changes Android also has a very
important set of developers doing what I
would call graphics intensive apps so
this would be things like maps games
video things of this nature we do a lot
of it at Google as well and so that's
why into dotto we're also including a
very early preview of our new GPU
profiler and debugger so one of the big
problems with graphics intensive
development is you'll see a scene and
you get a problem and you're not really
sure exactly what caused it so one of
the things you'll find in the GPU
profiler is you're able to record and
replay the entire GPU stream frame by
frame
so you can understand and debug into GL
code so now graphics developers can
spend countless save countless hours
when debugging graphics rendering
problems
another thing I want to talk about is
core IDE improvements Android is built
on top of IntelliJ and being built on
top of IntelliJ means as fast as Android
studio itself has been innovating
IntelliJ zone incredibly rapid pace
propels us even faster all the time
now IntelliJ released their newest
version 15 just about three weeks ago in
Android studio 2.0 already fully
integrates IntelliJ 15 you'll see that
in the canary builds so there's a ton
that comes with IntelliJ 15 one of the
features I thought I would touch on in
particular because we care about it so
much is testing another thing we hear a
lot from developers is how critical it
is to be able to build high quality apps
by default IntelliJ includes a wide
range of new features for testing
including a test runner tool window it's
got inline statistics and test result
history you can right click and then
execute a test and we've also added on
that in studio itself with a couple of
key asks from the community one of the
things you guys asked us for is to be
able to run all test types together now
as you guys know in Android studio you
can have two test types unit tests and
Android tests and now you can have both
of those active at the same time one of
the things that means
so one of the things that means to is
you can now refactor seamlessly across
your code so you can make a change in
app code refactor it it will go across
all test types all right so I've talked
so far about coding talked about
building I've talked about IntelliJ and
everything that we got from them we've
talked about debugging testing I want to
touch on one final area and that's
deployment and making your app
discoverable one of the things that we
did in Toronto was work very closely
with the Google search team they have a
wonderful feature called deep linking
which allows you to expose your app so
that it can be found in the Google
search but one of the key questions is
ok how do I get this set up in my app so
we've added support for this in Android
studio 2.0 the first thing you'll find
is something called intention actions so
what this means is you can go into
Android studio and as you're in your
code it will suggest to you in line
where you need to put code and actually
expand and show you how to configure it
now the second thing we have is static
analysis so I'm sure you know none of
you guys in the audience much like Dave
Burke have ever made coding mistakes but
I will be honest and say I make them
frequently so the static analysis we
have in 2.0 will check and make sure
that your deep links are configured
correctly the third thing we've added is
real-time testing so you can actually
see whether Google can index and render
the app pages correctly
[Applause]
so with Android studio 2.0 we know we
still have a couple of users out there
who are using our Eclipse tools and we
wanted to say to you there's really no
better time than now to switch to
Android studio it is a massive speed
improvement and we believe it will
significantly accelerate your
development a couple other things we'd
say Android studio remains open source
free to all and there's just one more
thing we had wanted to talk about while
we were here with development I feel
like one of the most amazing feelings is
when you're in the flow you're relaxed
your coding is this timelessness where
you're incredibly productive and so it
was in the interest of enabling
developers to code like that that we
created a new feature that is called
Android studio instant run instant run
is designed so that you can make changes
in code or resources and they'll update
into your live app near more or less
instantly so
so as you're coding you can press the
Run button and your changes will deploy
live into the running app and you're
gonna find this is going to take you on
an average Android app about one to two
seconds now we are still expanding the
set of code changes that will be covered
in instant run you will find for those
of you who watch the canaries closely
and I know that's a lot of people in
this room it'll expand very rapidly over
the coming weeks but there's a few
things that we felt like we're important
from the beginning we know you guys are
using a ton of emulators you're using a
ton of devices and people out there are
running phones with a lot of different
versions of Android so I'll say a couple
if they about this couple things about
it from the outset first instant run
will work on virtually every emulator in
use today
second instant run will work on
virtually every current physical device
and third it will work on virtually
every version of Android that has
significant use today that is all the
way back to Ice Cream Sandwich or API
level 15
[Applause]
the web really became successful in the
early days because you could edit HTML
you could see how it looked on a browser
right away and now our goal is to bring
a similar lightweight feel to mobile
development we're incredibly grateful
for all the the feedback from our
community that's led us in this
direction we were talking about the
feature beforehand and we were talking
about Dave Burke I think he's giving you
a cool overview of what the early days
the hard days looked like for Android
development and we thought it would be
really neat to have Dave Burke come back
up on stage and demo for you
Android studio to do an instant run to
get a feel for the new lightweight way
to do mobile development so with that
I'd like to welcome Dave Burke back all
right so we will switch to the developer
machine here okay cool so preview
version of the IDE live coding what
could possibly go wrong all right so
what I've got here is I've got a video
shield this is a live tablet live
physical tablet we have a projecting
picture and picture on top of here I
have the latest version of Android
studio 2.0 I have an app that Rome Angie
and Matt sisters Joe pian help me create
it's a chess game it's got some cool
physically-based
lighting and what I want to do is show
you a couple of things I want to show
you changing resources I want to show
you changing code so if I change a
resource like an XML layout what we're
gonna do we call it a warm swap we're
gonna upload the new resources we're
going to invalidate the frame caches and
then we'll restart the activity but
before I do that let me just get the app
running so I'm gonna go control R so the
IDE is building the app compiling it
it's a to be installing it the package
manager is doing its thing it's Dex
opting and now it's gonna run the app so
you know takes takes a bit of time
previously in an old world you - every
time you made a code change you have to
go through that process so here's how it
looks with Android studio 2.0 so let's
say I want to change the background of
the setting screen so I go to my XML
layout and I want to add a background so
I've got a background bitmaps I want to
add here so I can just go Android
background like so if I can type like
that and then I have a drawable setup
this is a preview of
of Android see they oh okay all right
all right so we're all good
okay so what's cool here is that to run
it I just go control our it'll send up
the new okay it's gonna restart because
I I'd busted it so we'll change this in
a second so let me let me let the start
again here okay so you can see normally
what would happen there is that we just
we start the activity which would not
have a cause a reinstall so it's the
same thing that happens when you rotate
the screen
I'll change another resource this time I
won't mess it up so you can actually see
it work so there's a you can see it says
new button there I can change the string
and I can say new game like this dog
control are okay you know what I'm gonna
I'm gonna reset this on one of the one
of the advantages of a live stream by
the way is you can edit it after the
fact and so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna uninstall this app did it okay
okay so I'm showing you what real
development looks like this is good so
I'll leave you I'll leave you game there
right and I'll go back here and I will
remove this line here like that so and
now I will do a normal building compile
so it's gonna build a good pile and it's
gonna install it let's take a couple of
seconds okay now it's running so if I
add this line back in here like so and
then I just do my control are what it'll
do is we'll just restart the activity so
you'll see a little flicker and I just
restarts like that okay
now looks more interesting so we call
that a warm swap right so it's the same
things rotating the screen much more
interesting is when you want to do what
we call a hot swap and the way this
works is that we're instrumenting the
code and every time you compile we run
an analyzer and see if we can hot swap
out the code at runtime and so we can
change method implementations of a class
on the fly so if I go into the chess
activity up here and so we have this on
draw frame call so this is getting call
sixty times a second to update this
screen now if I change something like
let's change these values here and I
change this value here so what this will
do is it will turn the chess board into
a 3d animated scene so I just go ctrl R
the code dynamically changes and then
boom instantly it just updates
[Applause]
so it turns out that I work in a company
full of overachievers who were very good
at chess and I need an advantage so what
I'm gonna do is try to find an advantage
now the first thing anybody who watches
rugby and everything the All Blacks play
from New Zealand will know the trick to
winning is to intimidate your opponent
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go and
try and make my chess pieces larger so I
get the vertex mesh for my piece my
pieces so I gotta be let's see
player 1 I suppose to do that boom and
then what I'll do is I'll it'll write
over each of my pieces like this some
people on size get all the chess pieces
like that and then what we'll do is
we'll get each of my pieces one by one
the index I and then I have a
convenience method to set the scale and
then I'll set that to 0.75 seems like a
good intimidation factor like that and
then control or boom and the gold pieces
jump up like that
[Applause]
so also it's got an extra advantage I
think I'll make my opponents a little
smaller so I can just go come on D like
this by the way if you have not started
using studio the autocomplete and this
idea is kind of amazing like watch this
boom boom is super fast so let's make my
opponents 0.75 and of course that's
player to control our boom a little
black guys get small alright now it
turns eyes is the squirrelly little
opponents won't be easily intimidated I
need to have a more meaningful material
advantage so what I'm gonna do is get my
pieces again so I'm player 1 and then
I'm gonna gonna set whoops a little typo
so get get the pieces so I and then what
I'm gonna do is set the mesh and then
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna get the
vertex mesh for ask more powerful pieces
so I guess get mesh and then queen would
be good and then I like to go color so
we'll stick with that and then hit a
semicolon there and then control our
boom I'm not gonna win this game all
right so that's instant run it's pretty
awesome and that's available in the
canary channel this morning so you can
try it out it's it's a preview build
[Applause]
okay so we have a packed set of days
here at the Computer History Museum if
you're on the livestream we've got 15
more hours of content on day one we're
gonna focus on framework skills again
what's amazing here is we have the
Android engineering team who built these
features here so you can learn so much
from just talking to them they're a
friendly bunch mostly especially after
lunch and they've had their lunch before
so before lunch not so much day two
we're gonna focus on tooling and
performance I'm gonna talk about some of
the new features that we've added like
data binding we talked about some of the
Android testing frameworks the new doze
feature and much more we also have the
self-paced tutorials outside on lots of
Android topics everything from
performance to writing watch face faces
for underwear we'll also make those
available to people online later today
so you can try them at home so with that
I just want to say thank you so much for
your time and enjoy the rest of the
summit
[Music]